Je tend à croire que nous sommes dans la période «préhistorique» des interfaces d'ordinateurs.
C'est comme si elles n'étaient pas aussi profondes, ou engageantes émotionnellement qu'elles pourraient l'être,
et j'aimerais changer tout ça.
Image s'il vous plaît!
Ok. Alors, vous voyez, ceci est le genre de status quo des interfaces, n'est ce pas ?
C'est très plat, et plutôt rigide.
Bon, OK, vous pourriez le rendre un peu plus sexy et aller vers un Mac plus léché,
mais c'est quand même la même merde que nous avons eu pendant les dernières,
vous savez, 30 années.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Je veux dire, je crois que nous endurons beaucoup de merdes avec nos ordinateurs.
Je veux dire, on pointe et on clique, c'est comme les menus, les icones, c'est pratiquement du pareil au même.
Alors un type d'espace contenant de l'information que j'utilise comme inspiration est mon vrai bureau.
C'est tellement plus subtil, tellement plus viscéral
-- vous savez, ce qui est visible, ce qui ne l'est pas.
Et j'aimerais amener cette expérience dans l'espace de travail.
Alors j'ai fait -- voici BumpTop.
C'est comme une nouvelle approche par rapport à l'utilisation de l'espace de travail.
Alors vous pouvez faire entrer les choses en collision -- elles sont physiquement, vous voyez, manipulables,
et au lieu de «pointer et cliquer», c'est plutôt «pousser et tirer»,
les trucs entrent en collision tels que vous auriez deviné. Comme sur mon vrai bureau,
Je peux -- laissez moi attraper ceux-ci -- Je peux empiler les choses,
au lieu des dossiers auxquels nous sommes habitués.
Et lorsque les choses sont empilées, je peux faire une recherche en les plaçant en grille.
ou bien, vous savez, les consulter comme un livre,
ou je peux les disposer comme un jeu de cartes.
Lorsque qu'elles sont exposées, je peux tirer les choses vers un autre endroit, ou en effacer,
ou juste organiser toute une pile rapidement, vous savez, immédiatement, d'accord.
Et, c'est plutôt bien animé, au lieu des changements brusques que vous voyez dans les interfaces d'aujourd'hui.
Aussi, si je veux ajouter quelque chose à une pile, et bien, comment je fais ?
Je n'ai qu'à l'envoyer sur la pile, et c'est ajouté sur le dessus. C'est plutôt bien.
Aussi, d'autres trucs que nous pouvons faire
pour ces icones individuelles nous nous sommes dits -- je veux dire,
comment peut-on jouer avec le concept d'icone, et pousser l'idée plus loin?
Une des choses que je peux faire est de l'agrandir
si je veux y mettre l'emphase et la rendre plus importante.
Mais ce qui est vraiment bien c'est que puisqu'il y a un simulateur pour les lois de la physique qui travaille derrière tout ça,
elle devient plus lourde. Alors les trucs plus légers ne bougent pas vraiment
Mais si je la lance sur les plus petits, vous voyez?
(Rires)
Alors c'est mignon, mais c'est un aussi une façon subtile de faire passer de l'information.
Ceci est lourd, alors ça semble plus important. Alors c'est plutôt bien.
Même s'il y a des ordinateurs partout, le papier n'a pas vraiment disparu,
parce qu'il a beaucoup de, je crois, propriétés intéressantes.
Et nous voulions transférer certaines d'entre elles aux icones dans notre système.
Alors une des choses que vous pouvez faire avec nos icones, comme avec du vrai papier, est de les plier.
Comme du papier. Pour vous rappeler de quelque chose pour plus tard.
Ou, si vous voulez détruire quelque chose, vous pouvez le chiffonner,
et le lancer dans le coin.
Aussi, comme avec du papier, dans notre espace de travail
nous collons des choses sur le mur pour nous en rappeler plus tard,
et je peux faire la même chose ici,
et vous savez, vous voyez des notes «post-it» et des choses comme ça dans le bureau des gens.
Et je peux les prendre du mur lorsque je veux travailler avec.
Alors, une des critiques que cette approche organisationelle reçoit est,
vous savez, «D'accord, mon bureau est complètement en désordre. je ne veux pas ce désordre dans mon ordinateur.»
Alors, une solution que nous avons est une sorte d'alignement en grille,
comme -- alors vous obtenez un espace de travail plus traditionnel. Les choses sont plutôt alignées en grille.
Plus ennuyeux, mais vous pouvez toujours faire des collisions et pousser les choses.
Et vous pouvez toujours faire des choses amusantes comme construire une étagère sur votre espace de travail.
Brisons cette étagère. Voilà, l'étagère est brisée.
Je crois que au-delà des icones, un autre domaine d'application pour ce programme --
Je crois que ça s'applique à plus que seulement les icones et à votre espace de travail -- mais à l'organisation de photos.
Je crois que l'on peut vraiment enrichir la façon dont nous parcourons nos photos.
et la rendre comme si vous étiez avec votre famille sur la table de cuisine à regarder vos photos qui sont dans une boîte à chaussures.
Et je peux déplacer ces trucs. Ils sont tellement plus tangibles lorsque -- et manipulables --
et vous savez, je peux double-cliquer sur quelque chose pour le regarder.
Et je peux faire tous les trucs que je vous ai déjà montrés.
Alors je peux empiler les choses, je peux les consulter, je peux, vous voyez --
Alors, déplaçons cette photo à l'arrière, effaçons celle-là,
et je crois qu'il s'agit d'une façon beaucoup plus riche d'interagir avec vos données.
Et voilà BumpTop. Merci!